- [Narrator] Orbiting the Earth
at 17,500 miles per hour...
- [Speaker] Oh, there it went.
- [Narrator] Is the Space Station.
Or, I'm sorry: The
International Space Station,
because there's two now.
The international one used
by the US, Russia, Europe,
Canada, Japan, and others;
and China's Tiangong, which
became fully operational
at the end of 2022.
They plan to use it for at
least the next 10 to 15 years.
Meanwhile, the International Space Station
is set to be retired before that.
- International Space
Station is going down.
Chinese space station is going up.
I won't say it's a changing of the guard,
but does indicate that
things are changing.
The people who are up
in space are changing.
The evolution of use of space is changing.
- [Narrator] Chinese and US
astronauts aren't allowed
on their opposing space stations.
They are effectively banned
from directly working together
because of one small
section in a 2011 law.
Here's why the US and China
don't work together in space,
and why that law is now a big
debate in the space community.
Leading up to the amendment,
there was a lot of tension
between the US and China.
There were numerous cyber attacks,
including on members of Congress.
- On these computers was information
about all the case work I've done
on behalf of political dissonance
and human rights activists
around the world.
- [Narrator] In 2007, China completed
a ballistic missile test,
creating a tremendous amount of debris
when it destroyed a weather satellite;
debris the International Space Station
still has to maneuver around.
In news stories at the time,
the concern wasn't
immediately the station,
but the showing of China's military might.
- Space is a key national
security enabler.
- [Narrator] Victoria Samson
works for an organization
that promotes global cooperation in space.
Her career has focused
on that intersection between
space and the military.
- There's kind of a natural correlation
between a ballistic missile program
and a satellite launch program.
That was only the third country
to do that sort of thing.
The US and the Soviet Union had done them
during the Cold War, but there
hadn't been one officially
for decades at that point.
I think that was really kind of a reminder
that there are new actors
in space and new interests,
and so the United States needed to think
about how it wants to deal with space.
- [Narrator] Then, in 2010,
the head of NASA went to China
to begin talks of collaborating together,
possibly even on the
International Space Station.
As he described it in 2021...
- Before I went, met with Congressman Wolf
because he was the chairman
of the House Appropriations Committee
responsible for NASA funding,
and he asked me not to go.
In fact, he told me not to go.
- [Narrator] He's talking
about that Congressman,
Frank Wolf, who was
passionate about investigating
and punishing China's human rights abuses,
and felt that even
normalizing trade with China
in the 90s was...
- Fundamentally immoral,
and this Congress is ready
to ratify a fundamentally immoral policy,
a policy that has no morality behind it.
- [Narrator] In 2011, he added a clause
to that NASA funding bill
that says the space agency
can't participate, collaborate,
or coordinate bilaterally
in any way with China
or any Chinese-owned companies,
unless it's approved by Congress.
It's called the Wolf Amendment.
It's not a total ban,
but it's created what
many call speed bumps,
which functionally serve
to ban collaboration.
- The Wolf Amendment does
not prevent the United States
from doing things with
China on space issues,
but it does send a message
that the United States
is leery about working
with China on space issues.
- [Narrator] The US has long used space
as kind of a soft power.
The US-Russia relationship
was a key example of that,
working together on
compatible docking systems
despite the Cold War,
and then, of course, the Space Station.
- The International Space Station
has been a very effective
tool for diplomatic outreach.
But, you know, the United
States wasn't reaching out
to other countries out of the
goodness of their own heart,
and it felt that there were benefits
that the program could get
from the various partners.
The Russians had, you know, experience
under the Soviet Union of
having their own space stations.
They would bring that tactical expertise.
- [Narrator] China originally wasn't part
of the International Space Station,
because they just didn't
have the technical knowledge
at the time.
This is the total amount
of launches conducted
by the US and Russia,
and here's China.
In 2011, while their space
program had improved,
they were still far behind,
or as Congressman Wolf said at the time,
he didn't want to give
China the opportunity
to take advantage of our technology,
and we have nothing to gain
from dealing with them.
But a decade later, things have changed.
(rocket roaring)
(person speaking indistinctly)
China has been quickly stepping
up how often it launches,
and the future plans of both countries
will be in the same place: the Moon.
NASA says they plan to have
a crewed mission in 2025,
look to establish a longer
term presence there,
and in the years ahead,
establish another
multinational space station,
the Lunar Gateway, that
will orbit the moon.
China says they also plan to have a camp
on the same part of the moon by 2028.
But if these two base camps
wanna coordinate or collaborate,
they need to go to Congress
30 days in advance.
- Particularly when you're looking
at such a hostile
environment such as the Moon,
it seems foolish to needlessly
complicate relationships
and create a hostile working environment
with one of the only other countries
that perhaps could help out
human beings on the moon,
just because you have hostile
relationships on the ground.
- [Narrator] That's why there's a debate
in the space community
about whether this law should
exist in its current form.
- If you look at what was
Congressman Frank Wolf's purpose,
which was to try to isolate the Chinese
and to, more closely,
abiding with our norms
in human rights, it did not
accomplish its purpose at all.
If we're looking at slowing
their program or keeping them
from developing a space program,
it did not do that at all.
Unfortunately, what it
has done has caused us
to now be on the outside looking in,
as China presses forward with
their 50 year space program
and doing things that some people say
they're moving at an incredible pace.
- [Narrator] Congressman
Wolf, who is now retired,
told the Wall Street
Journal in a statement
that if a planned
collaboration doesn't meet
the amendment's basic criteria,
NASA has no business doing it,
and referred to China's
continuing human rights abuses.
- I think the Wolf
Amendment is gonna be around
for a while, partially
because no one wants
to spend the political
capital to get rid of it,
partially because I think
the pendulum has really swung
in terms of concerns about
China as a rival or threat.
- They could go to the
South Pole of the Moon
where the resources are,
and they could land,
and they would say, "This
is our exclusive territory.
You stay out."
And we're not gonna let that happen.
- [Narrator] The Wolf
Amendment has been kept
in each NASA funding
bill since its creation,
but as the US and China both
move closer to the Moon,
the space community's
debate over collaboration
may become a congressional one.
(relaxing music)